you are one of the great historians of
our time specializing in the man the
leader the historical figure of stalin
so let me ask a challenging question
if you can uh perhaps
think about the echo of 80 years between
joseph stalin and vladimir putin what
are the similarities and differences
between the man and the historical
figure the historical trajectory of
stalin and putin
thank you alex it's very nice to be here
again with you
it's been a while good to see you yeah
good to see you as well you're looking
good
i see this
podcast stuff is doing you right yeah
so we can't really put very easily
vladimir putin in the same sentence with
joseph stahl
stalin
is a singular figure
and his category is really small
hitler
mao
that's really about it
and even in that category stalin is the
dominant figure
both by how long he was in power and
also by the amount of power the
military-industrial complex he helped
build and commanded
so putin can't be compared to that
neither
on actually on any scale
however putin's in the same building
as stalin he uses some of the same
offices as stalin used
and some of those
the television broadcasts that we see of
putin at meetings and putin inside the
kremlin
stalin used to sit in those rooms and
hold meetings in those rooms that's the
imperial senate
built by catherine the great an 18th
century building
inside the kremlin
it's a domed building
and and you can see it on the panorama
the top of the building at least you can
see it on the panorama when you look
over the kremlin wall from many sites
inside moscow
so
if he's not
comparable to stalin he still works as i
said in those same buildings those same
offices
partly and so therefore he's got some of
the problems that stalin had
which was managing russian power in the
world
from a position of weakness vis-a-vis
the west
but from a an ambition a grandiosity
in fact
and so this combination of weakness
and grandeur
right of of not being as strong as the
west but aspiring
to be as great or greater than the west
that's the dilemma of russian history
for the past many centuries it was the
dilemma for the tsars it was the dilemma
for peter the great it was the dilemma
for alexander
it was the dilemma for stalin and it's
the dilemma for putin russia is smaller
now
compared to when stalin was in that
kremlin
it's got pushed back to borders
almost the time of peter the great
its father from the main european
capitals now than any time
since that 18th century
and it and the west has only grown
stronger in that period of time so the
dilemma is greater than ever
the irony of being in that position
of sitting in the kremlin trying to
manage russian power in the world trying
to be a providential power
a country with a special mission in the
world
a country which imagines itself to be a
whole civilization
and yet not having the capabilities to
meet those aspirations
and falling farther and farther behind
the west
the irony of all that is the attempted
solutions
put russia in a worse place every single
time
so you try to manage the gap with the
west you try to realize these
aspirations
you try to raise your capabilities
and you build a strong state the quest
to build a strong state and use coercive
modernization
to try somehow if not to close the gap
with the west at least to manage it and
the result is
different versions of personalist rule
so they don't build a strong state
they build a personal dictatorship they
build an autocracy
and moreover that autocracy undertakes
measures which then worsen the very
geopolitical dilemma
that gave rise to this
personalist rule in the first place and
so i call this russia's perpetual
geopolitics i've been writing about this
for many many years
what's important about this analysis
is this is not a story of eternal
russian
cultural proclivity to aggression
right it's not something that's in the
mother's milk it's not something that
can't be changed
russia doesn't have
an innate cultural tendency to
aggression this is a choice it's a
strategic choice
to try to match the power of the west
which from russia's
vantage point is actually unmatchable
but it's a choice that's made again and
again and putin has made this choice
just the stalin made the choice right
stalin presided over the world war ii
victory
and then he lost the peace
after he died in 1953
there was of course other rulers who
succeeded him he was still the most
important person in the country after he
died
because they were trying to manage that
system that he built and more
importantly manage that growing gap with
the west
by the time the 90s rolled around
former soviet troops now russian troops
withdrew from all those advanced
positions
that they had achieved as a result of
the world war ii victory and it was
napoleon in reverse
they went on the same roads
but not from moscow back to paris
but instead from
warsaw and from east berlin and from
tallinn and regan and all the other
places of former warsaw pact and former
soviet republics
in the baltic region
they went back to russia in retreat and
so stalin in the fullness of time lost
the peace
and putin
in his own way
inheriting some of this
attempting to reverse it
when
as i said russia was smaller farther
away weaker the west was bigger and
stronger and and had absorbed
those former warsaw pact
uh countries and baltic states because
they voluntarily begged
to join the west the west didn't impose
itself on them it's a voluntary sphere
of influence that the west conducts
and so that dilemma is where you can put
putin and stalin in the same sentence
and the terrible outcome for russia
in the fullness of time
also has echoes but of course putin
hasn't murdered 18 to 20 million people
and the scale of his abilities to cause
grief
uh with the nuclear weapons aside is
nothing like stalin's and so we have to
be careful right only mao
put bigger numbers on the board
from a tragic point of view than stalin
and numbers matter here
if we compare these singular figures
yeah mal killed more people than stalin
because mao had more people to kill
the most amazing thing about mao is he
watched stalin do it
he watched stalin collectivize
agriculture and famine result
he watched stalin impose this communist
monopoly
and all of those people sent to prison
or given a bullet in the back of the
neck he watched all of that and then he
did it again himself in china do you
think he saw the human cost directly
that that when you say he saw do you
think he was focused on the policies
or was he also aware distinctly as a
human being of the
human costs in the lives of peasants and
the in the lives of the working class
and lies at the poor
i think the prima facie evidence is that
he didn't value human life
otherwise i don't think after seeing the
amount of lives that were taken in the
soviet experiment he would have done
something similar after that
i think the answer lex is
it's very hard to get inside mouse head
and figure out what he was really
thinking
but if you just look at the results that
happened the policies that were
undertaken and the consequences of them
you would have to conclude that there
was
let's say no value or little value
placed on human life
unfortunately that's characteristic not
only of communist dictators right of
post-communist dictators as well but the
scale
of the horrors that they inflict
as horrific as they are
just can't compare
and so we're in a situation where
eurasia
that is to say
the ancient civilizations of eurasia
which would be russia iran
china
all have
some version of non-democratic you know
illiberal autocratic regimes
and they're all pushing up against the
greater power of the west in some form
sometimes they coordinate their actions
and sometimes they don't
but this is a very long-standing
phenomenon lex that predates
of vladimir
putin or xi jinping
or the latest incarnation of the supreme
leader in iran
you